Republicans are now making fun of  Ukrainian President Vladimir zelenski's  height his height Ann Coulter tweeting  in response to something on the Internet  that says zelenski is 5'7 saying all men  add two inches to their height which  means he's 5'5 at best this is where we  are at this point in time they I guess  have gotten tired or have run out of  ways to defend Putin  so instead they're going after zelenski  for his height now of course when we  went after and we didn't really go after  when it was mentioned that the size of  Donald Trump's  hands is very small these very same  right Wingers said oh that's out of  school that's that's that that's a  bridge too far you shouldn't be talking  about that sort of thing keep it policy  oriented and now it's all about  zelenski's height these people are  pathetic but they're also hypocrites